welcome to my first ever angular
tutorial for beginners if you've learned
a little bit about JavaScript HTML and
CSS the next step is to make the world a
better place by building an app that
people can use today we'll build a
tic-tac-toe game from scratch deploy it
and make it installable on desktop and
mobile applications as a PWM and despite
angular's reputation as an
enterprise-grade framework you might be
very surprised at how easy it is to
start being productive with angular even
as a beginner and you'll especially love
it when you start building complex
products in real life if you're new here
like and subscribe and if you want to
get really deep into angular check out
my new angular course on fire ship IO
first of all what is angular because the
word angular refers to so many different
things it's a declarative UI framework a
code bundler a tool for building
progressive web apps
it handles server-side rendering
provides libraries for forms testing
animation and so much more and it's all
wrapped up in a highly performant
package that will help reduce decision
fatigue web developers especially have a
huge number of open-source libraries to
choose from when building a product and
the status quo is always changing wait a
minute angular ships with a ton of
features out of the box many of which
anticipate the complexity that you'll
face as your app grows but almost all of
its features are optional and can be
adopted as needed so what does angular
really do at its core then the short
answer is that it helps you build
complex cross-platform applications
using web technology like JavaScript
HTML and CSS but I think the best way to
answer that question is to just show you
by building something from scratch so
over the next 15 minutes or so we'll
build a tic-tac-toe game we'll add a
design system to it we'll make it a
progressive web app we'll deploy it and
finally install it on our local system
as if it were a native desktop or mobile
app that might sound like a lot to do in
15 minutes
but don't worry we have a superpower
known as the angular command-line
interface and this is not your typical
CLI this thing is really powerful
because of angular's conventions we can
generate a lot of code automatically at
this point I'm assuming you have no js'
installed on your system and will run
npm install global at angular CLI this
will give you access to the ng command
in your terminal and the first thing
we'll want to do is generate a new
angular app we can do that by running ng
new with the name of the app and it will
ask us if we want to add routing we'll
go ahead and say yes and we'll choose
SCSS for our styles and then we'll go
ahead and open up our app in vs code
there's a couple of extensions you'll
want to have first is the angular
language service which will give you
syntax highlighting in your HTML
templates and then I'm also installing
the angular console which is a tool that
allows us to simply point and click on
CLI commands as opposed to typing them
out manually in the terminal go ahead
and find the serve command then hit run
what happens is that our code is now
bundled with web pack using live reload
so every time we make a change to our
code it will be reflected in the browser
and you can see that on localhost 4200
now if you're new to web development you
may have not experienced this yet but
one of the most painful aspects of the
job it can be bundling your code when
building a web application you need to
target multiple browsers and on top of
that you want to keep the JavaScript
bundle size as small as possible doing
this from scratch in a complex
application is a major pain but not with
angular click the build command and see
what happens
angular will automatically minify and
bundle your code and will also generate
multiple bundles for a differential
loading this means the browser will
always load the smallest javascript
bundle possible based on the features
available in that browser and we can see
all that raw JavaScript code by going
into the dist folder and this is the
folder that we would actually deploy to
a production hosting account or server
now let's take a look at some of the
files in this initial application we
have a few TS config files here which
were automatically generated and set up
for this project angular was really the
first major framework to encourage the
use of typescript and you now see it is
almost a standard on large complex
projects
[Music]
now the default angular app also comes
with testing using karma and Jasmine but
there are other schematics or other
extensions for the CLI you can use for
other testing frameworks like jest and
cypress and that's just another thing
that angular does out-of-the-box it sets
up your testing utilities so you don't
have to think about configuring them but
what good is any of this if the
framework doesn't actually help us build
a front-end UI because angular at its
core is very similar to other UI
frameworks like react spelt and view
just to name a few
you'll find these same concepts in
angular that you find in these
frameworks component based UI
architecture where you can pass
properties or data from one component to
another the place where we write our
actual UI code is in the source app
directory by default angular generates
an app component which is essentially
the entry point into the app we can see
how this works by opening up the
index.html file which is just plain HTML
the special thing is that we have this
app root element in the body this
element will be replaced with our actual
angular JavaScript application and that
initial parsing of the JavaScript is
called bootstrapping
but the main thing you'll be doing in
angular is creating a UI by building and
composing components together and there
are three main pieces to any component
the component typescript is where you
define your custom javascript logic and
also define the internal state of the
component then you have your HTML which
contains the actual visual UI and allows
you to bind data from the typescript to
that template and lastly you have a
style sheet which is scoped to that
component meaning these Styles won't
bleed out to other components let's go
into the app component HTML first and
delete all of the boilerplate code in
there leaving only the router outlet
angular provides a very powerful router
out of the box which allows you to map
components to URLs in the browser and
the router can even help you do
something called code splitting with web
pack to lazy load certain parts of your
JavaScript bundle we're not going to
cover it in this video but just know
that it's a relatively complex thing
that angular makes trivial now from this
point I want to build something
meaningful so let's build a little game
of tic-tac-toe the idea itself is
inspired by the react to toriel and it
provides a good baseline for
understanding the mechanics of the
framework
we'll start by building a bare-bones
game then we'll add a design system and
lastly we will deploy it as a PWA so the
first thing we'll do is generate a
component to represent an individual
square will find the generate command
with the angular console will generate a
component and give it a name up Square
and a lot of times in angular you might
not need to have your component
separated into three different files so
when running this command from the
angular console we'll actually select
the options for inline template and
inline styles you'll see this created a
square directory along with a square
component inside if we open up the
component you'll see that we're
importing a component and on an it from
angular core on an it is what's known as
a lifecycle hook which allows you to run
some code when the component is first
initialized it's not required for this
component so I'm going to go ahead and
delete the references to it and what
we're left with here is just a plain
angular component every component starts
with a component decorator and
decorators are these things that start
with an @ symbol and you can watch my
full video on typescript decorators if
you're curious to learn how they work
but in the case of angular they allow us
to pass in an object that configures the
way this component behaves first you'll
notice the selector option this is the
name of the component as it will be
declared or used in the HTML let's go
ahead and open the app component to see
how that works if we start typing Apps
Square it should autocomplete in vs code
and then we can hit tab to complete it
and then if we're still serving the app
we should see the content of that
component in the web page the next thing
you'll notice is the template angular
provides a special templating language
that empowers your HTML with JavaScript
like logic you can use conditional
expressions loops and bind data directly
to the HTML to write templates that are
expressive and easy to understand and
also highly performant when it comes to
reacting to data changes within the app
and that's why declarative UI frameworks
like react angular etc are so popular
they make it easy for you as a developer
to keep your app data in sync with the
actual UI how it appears visually for
the end user in angular we can bind data
to a template by simply adding it as a
property to the component class just to
demonstrate this I'll add a random
number and then I can interpolate it in
the template by using double braces
and now we should see the random number
in the screen under the hood angular is
doing a thing called change detection
where it's looking for changes to these
properties and then updating the UI in a
highly performant way and all we have to
do from a development perspective is
change the value of the property for
example if we set up an interval here
and change the random number to a
different random number you'll see it's
updated in the screen every 500
milliseconds so when you set a property
on a component class that's like setting
its internal state but in many cases you
want to pass in the property from a
parent component and that's exactly what
we want for this square we can allow
properties to be input into this
component by using the input decorator
if we start typing input and then tab it
will automatically import this decorator
for us and then we can set the property
name to value and we could even use
typescript here to limit this value to a
certain subset of string values or some
other type if we wanted to and now we
can go back up to our component
declaration in the app component and now
we can input this value from the parent
component which can be just a string
value or if we're at value in brackets
it will take an actual expression or a
dynamic value from this parent component
and that means you can pass a complex
object from parent to child now if we
look at our square component it only has
a single input there is nothing in this
component that allows it to modify its
own state it all comes from the parent
so we generally call this a UI component
or a dump component dump components are
a good thing they're easy to test and
they're only concerned about the UI so
there's not much to worry about in terms
of bugs and things like that but in
order to build a tic-tac-toe game we'll
need some kind of smart component to
manage the state or the data between the
various squares let's go ahead and
generate that component will call it
board and just stick with the default
options now our board component will be
our smart component meaning it has
internal state they can change we have
the squares property which represents
the nine moves on the game board which
will be an array of strings and then we
have a property called X's next which is
a boolean to help us determine the
current player and then we have the
winner which will either be X or O now
every component has a constructor and
also lifecycle hooks the constructor
runs immediately when this class is
created but you don't generally do
anything in the constructor aside from
inject your dependencies which we'll
look at in a future video if you have
initial setup work that needs to be done
in a component you'll use the ng on a
net life cycle hook in most cases in our
case we'll write a method on this
component called new game and its
responsibility is to set up the initial
values when starting a brand new game
for our squares property we'll create an
array with nine elements in it and then
we'll fill them with null values
initially when a user clicks on a square
these values will be spliced with either
an X or an O we'll set the winner to
null and X is next to true
now when working with data on a
component you may want to compute a
property based on one of the main pieces
of data that changes in our case X is
next determines which player is
currently using the game board that's a
boolean value but we'd also like to show
the name of the player as a string which
would be X or O so we can create a
computed property by using a type script
getter we'll go ahead and call this
property player and if X is next is true
then the next player will be X otherwise
it will be o now anytime the X is next
value changes this computed property
will be changed and reflected in the UI
as well now the next thing we'll do in
this component is define a method which
will serve as an event handler for when
the user clicks on one of the buttons to
make a move when that click event
happens we'll check the index in the
array that they clicked on if that
Square has already been clicked then we
won't do anything but if it's empty or
null and we'll splice in the index of
the square that user clicked on with the
current player that we've computed in
this component and then we'll also
toggle the X's next boolean to its
opposite value by using an exclamation
mark in the last thing I'll do is write
a method called calculate winner this
code mostly comes from the react to
toriel and it's basically just an
algorithm that determines if the user
has won the tic-tac-toe game I'm not
going to spend time explaining the exact
implementation details but feel free to
copy the source code from the github
link in the video description so now
let's head into the HTML template to see
how we can bind the data properties we
define on the component class to our
actual UI
we'll want to show the name of the
current player show the winner if the
exist and then also loop over the array
of squares so the user has something to
click on the player property that we
defined what they get her behaves just
like any other property we can simply
use it with the handle bar syntax to
interpolate it in the template now the
other thing that you'll commonly do in a
web application is handle events and an
angular we can bind to events by using
parentheses and you'll notice that when
we do that angular's tooling will
automatically give us a list of all the
possible events to add here and then we
bind a handler to this event which vs
code will also autocomplete so in
angular you get amazing tooling both in
the typescript and also in your
templates now for this tic-tac-toe game
if we have a winner we want to display a
conditional template only when that
winner exists and we can make that
happen with what's called a structural
directive if you type in star you'll see
the different structural directives at
your disposal but the most common one is
ngf and it allows you to only render the
HTML that it's bound to if the value on
the right side evaluates to true or it
can be coerced to a truth eval you to be
more precise and so when the winner is
present then this h2 element will be
rendered in the Dom now the final step
is to put together the actual squares
that represent the game board another
common structural directive and angular
is ng4 so first we'll declare our app
square component then we'll add ng4 to
render this component multiple times
based on the array of squares inside of
ng4 we say let vowel which creates a
template variable named vowel that we
can now use in this template and if we
also want access to the index we can set
a template variable of I equal to the
index and now we can put these variables
to use the first thing we want to do is
pass the value down to the child app
square component and it can use that
value to render an X or an O in the
button and we'll also bind to the click
event to make a move on that index when
the user clicks on the square now that
takes care of our template logic but
there's one thing that's missing and
that is our CSS styling to give us a 3x3
grid CSS grid makes this very easy we
just set up our main element to display
grid and then we'll display the columns
at 200 pixels each at this point you can
serve the application and you should now
be able to play a game of tic-tac-toe
but we have one major problem at this
point the app looks horrible so what
we'd like to do is add some global
styling like a design system to give us
a consistent UI that looks great but
usually setting up something like that
is pretty involved but fortunately the
angular ecosystem has a variety of
third-party component libraries that we
can easily add to this project with a
single command and that means our app
can look great right out of the gate
without any decision making or
configuration on our part
there are plenty of great options to
choose from like angular material ionic
and others but today we're going to go
with nebula not only do the default
components look great but they also just
released a new feature called UI bakery
and it's a tool that allows you to
visually create components and then
download angular code expect a video on
this topic in the near future for right
now we'll go ahead and add nebula to
this project by using the ng add command
if we run ng ad at nebula theme it will
automatically install and configure
nebula in our project I'm gonna go ahead
and choose the cosmic theme because that
sounds cool and we'll also say yes to
customization and animation you'll
notice a few key changes to the project
we now have a themes s CSS file which we
can use to customize the variables used
in the theme and then we can go into the
app module and we'll see that we have a
few ng module is imported here we're not
going to talk about ng modules in this
video but they are discussed in detail
in the full course basically they're
just a mechanism that makes it possible
to use angular in a progressive way or
in other words only use the parts of the
framework that you actually need in our
case we'll go ahead and import the
nebular button module because that's the
only nebula component that we want to
use so we don't have to package the
entire thing which would increase our
bundle size and decrease performance and
also if we go into the app component
you'll see that we now have a bunch of
components that are prefixed by NB for
nebula and already the UI is looking a
lot more interesting but one obvious way
we can improve this is to change the
styling of an individual square based on
its state if we go back into our square
component we now have access to the NB
button directive with this directive you
can apply the nebular button theme and
behaviors to any HTML element using the
directive as is we'll give you the
default nebular button which we'll go
ahead and do when the value is null or
when the square has not been selected
then we'll go ahead and set up a couple
of
additional buttons as well and these
buttons will take additional properties
on the NB button directive and the
design system provides a lot of
different ways to customize the button
right out-of-the-box for example we'll
use this hero button which gives it a
nice little gradient but check out the
component library and the docs for a
full set of examples then we'll
conditionally render each button
depending on whether or not the value is
X or O
using the ngf directive now I realize
I'm going through this code very fast
but again make sure to reference the
link to github in the video description
to find the full project source code and
one last thing I'll do is also go into
the board component and for the start
new game button we'll go ahead and
display an outline button there and with
just a few minor changes we now have a
much better looking game of tic-tac-toe
so this kind of highlights my favorite
thing about angular and that is getting
things done quickly the tooling truly is
amazing and there's a lot less
configuration required to get to
something meaningful but there's still
one more thing I promised you and that's
to make this a progressive web app that
can be installed as a native app and
believe it or not that's actually the
easiest part of this entire video let's
head over to the angular console click
on add and then you'll see a full list
of the different schematics that are
available to you the one we're
interested in is at angular /pwa when
you run this command it does several
important things related to pwace the
first thing it does is add the
JavaScript code needed to load a
serviceworker in the angular app and
then it gives you a configuration file
that you can use to customize the
behavior of the serviceworker and the
worker is there primarily to make your
app work offline so you can customize
the behavior of how those pages are
cached and stored offline and then
you'll also notice that it adds a
manifest file and some icons for the
actual install button for the app now in
order to determine if we have a valid
progressive web app we need to run this
app in a production environment so the
first step in that process is to run ng
build which we can do with the angular
console and that will compile all of our
typescript code down to JavaScript in
the dist folder there's just one thing
missing and that's an actual place to
deploy our code my personal favourite
place is firebase and we can easily add
firebase to an angular project by
running ng add at angular fire this is
going to ask you for a firebase project
so you'll need to have signed up for a
firebase account if you
don't have one already and firebase
hosting can be used on the free tier by
the way the only thing left to do at
this point is run ng deploy that's going
to automatically deploy our production
app to the firebase hosting account that
will give you the hosting URL when it's
finished and now we can play tic-tac-toe
on the web but here's the coolest thing
about this if we go to the audits tab in
chrome dev tools we can analyze our app
as a PWA and you can see we hit the
green check marks on everything and what
this means for the end user is that the
app is now installable on their device
and pwace are supported pretty much
everywhere now in fact we can even
install it on Windows desktop by hitting
the install button in chrome it will add
a shortcut to the desktop and it will
open up the app in an actual Windows
window and now people can use your web
app as if it were a traditional desktop
app and the same goes for mobile apps as
well so I'll just finish up by saying
that angular is a really awesome tool
when you know how to use it and if you
want to go beyond the basics and learn
how to build a real world progressive
web app consider becoming a pro member
at fire ship IO you'll get access to the
brand new angular 8 course and a whole
bunch of other Pro content thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]